Y
ENJOY YOUR MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND,
WE APPRECIATE IT, GOOD SPIRITED
DEBATE, THANK YOU.
ALSO DEVELOPING A TONIGHT, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES
TO GO SOFT ON CHINA DESPITE
INCREASING EVIDENCE SUPPORTING
THE THEORY THAT WE WEREN'T ABOUT
THE WHOLE TIME WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS ORIGINS.
WHEN ASKED YESTERDAY OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WOULD SEEK
TO PUNISH CHINA FOR THEIR
COVER-UP, BIDEN'S PRINCIPAL
DEPUTY PRESS SECRETARY REPLIED
"WE ARE NOT GOING TO GO THERE
JUST YET."
THE NEW HOUSE BILLS WOULD LAUNCH
A CORONAVIRUS ORIGINS PROBE AND
ALLOW THE ALLOW VICTIMS FAMILIES
TO SUE BEIJING AND THAT'S NOT
ALL.
WE ARE ALSO LEARNING THE U.S.
REPORTEDLY HAS UNEXAMINED
INTELLIGENCE ON WHERE EXACTLY
THE VIRUS STARTED.
AND GET THIS, FORMER TRUMP
OFFICIAL PART OF THE FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE PROBE INTO
THE VIRUS SAYS THE INVESTIGATION
FOUND ALMOST NO EVIDENCE, AND
ZERO SUPPORTING THE NATURAL
ORIGIN THEORY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE WERE FINDING THAT DESPITE
THE CLAIMS OF OUR SCIENTIFIC
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING DR. FAUCI
THAT THERE WAS ALMOST NO
EVIDENCE THAT SUPPORTED AN
EVOLUTION, THE DATA
DISPROPORTIONATELY STACKED UP AS
WE INVESTIGATED TO BE COMING OUT
OF THE LAB OR SOME SUPERNATURAL
SOURCE.
>> Dan: BUT THE BIDEN TEAM
DIDN'T WANT TO ENTERTAIN THAT
THEORY AND SHUT THE PROBE DOWN
IN THE SPRING.
SO I DON'T WANT TO HEAR ANYMORE
NONSENSE OR TALK FROM BONEHEADED
LIBS ABOUT SO-CALLED CONSPIRACY
THEORIES FROM THIS POINT ON,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MEDIA AND BIG TECH HAVE ALL
BEEN CAUGHT WITH THEIR PANTS
DOWN AGAIN CENSORING AND TRYING
TO SUPPRESS INFORMATION THAT
GOES AGAINST THEIR POLITICAL
AGENDA.
JOIN ANY NOW WITH REACTION,
RIC GRENELL ALONG WITH THEIR
WELL I SAID.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CONGRESSMAN, I'LL GO TO YOU
FIRST.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY COMMON SENSE
THAT THE LAB LEAK THEORY SHOULD
AT LEAST BE ANALYZED.
WE HAVE A CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC
THAT ORIGINATED IN WUHAN, A
CORONAVIRUS LAB IN WUHAN THAT
HAD BEEN CITED FOR SECURITY
PROBLEMS IN THE PAST.
AND BY THE WAY, FOUND OUT WE HAD
INTELLIGENCE THAT THREE WORKERS
IN THE LAB GOT SICK WITH A
CORONAVIRUS TYPE ILLNESS.
WAS THIS NOT THE MOST OBVIOUS
THING TO LOOK AT AND YET WE WERE
CALLED LUNATICS AND CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS FOR DARING TO BRING IT
UP?
>> MY LATE FATHER ALWAYS SAID IF
SOMEONE LOOKS GUILTY, COULD BE
BECAUSE THEY ARE GUILTY.
WHEN YOU HAVE THOSE KINDS OF
INDICATIONS, THE IMPORTANT THING
TO DO IS TO FOLLOW THE FACTS AND
THE MEDIA HAS TOLD US NOT TO
FOLLOW THE FACTS, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS DENIED THEM,
BUT THE PRESSURE IS GOING FOR A
REAL COMMISSION.
WE HAVE 3,000 PLUS PEOPLE DIED
ON 9/11 AND WE KNEW SOME OF THE
FACTS BUT STILL HAD A COMMISSION
THAT DEALT DEEPLY TO MAKE SURE
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
WE NOW HAVE 600,000 PEOPLE DEAD,
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF DAMAGE
TO OUR ECONOMY, COUNTLESS
GREATER AMOUNTS TO THE ENTIRE
WORLD, OF COURSE WE HAVE TO LOOK
INTO IT AND ALL POSSIBILITIES
AND PROBABILITIES.
>> Dan: YOU'VE BEEN AN
ABSOLUTE WARRIOR FOR THE TRUTH.
I FOLLOW YOU AND REALLY ENJOY
YOUR SOCIAL MEDIA READING AND
YOU HAVE NO PROBLEM GOING BACK
AND FORTH ON THESE MEDIA PROBES.
AND WHEN ARE THEY GOING TO GET A
STORY RIGHT?
THE COLLUSION HOAX, THE TAPE,
ARE THEY EVER GOING TO GET A
STORY RIGHT?
THEY SPENT FOUR YEARS WASTING
OUR TIME WITH BOB MUELLER ON
THAT, THIS TRAGIC GLOBAL
PANDEMIC WIPE DOWN WITH LIES AND
ARE THEY EVER GOING TO PUT THESE
GUYS IN THE FACE AGAIN?
>> OUTSIDE OF WASHINGTON, NO ONE
HAS FAITH IN THEM.
THEY LOOK AT WASHINGTON AND THEY
SAY EVERYTHING THAT GOES ON
THERE, THEY JUST TALK AMONGST
THEMSELVES AND WHAT NEWSROOMS
BELIEVE IS NOT WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BELIEVE.
LET ME JUST DEFEND THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY HERE FOR
A MINUTE.
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING, IF YOU
GO BACK AND LOOK BACK AT
APRIL 30TH, 2020.
THE STATEMENT FROM THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, THE
AGREEMENT WAS THE COVID-19
STARTED IN CHINA AND THAT IT WAS
EITHER THE WET MARKET OR THE LAB
AND THAT WE WOULD BEGIN TO LOOK
AT INFORMATION OVER TIME AND WE
WOULD ALWAYS BRING FORWARD
INFORMATION.
THE MEDIA NEVER UNDERSTOOD WITH
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITIES
WERE SAYING.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT IS
UNEXAMINED, THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY EVERY SINGLE DAY
EXAMINED EVERY PIECE THAT THEY
HAD AND BUBBLED IT UP.
ANYONE IS CONFUSED AS TO WHAT
THE EVIDENCE IS SHOWING, IT IS
JOE BIDEN AND THE MEDIA.
THE EVIDENCE HAS BEEN THERE.
I'D LIKE TO ASK WHY JOE BIDEN IS
SUDDENLY ASKING FOR A REVIEW, A
90 DAY REVIEW OF THE EVIDENCE.
WE DON'T HOLD BACK EVIDENCE IN
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
HE HASN'T SEEN EVIDENCE, IS
BECAUSE -- THAT'S A REAL
PROBLEM.
>> Dan: FROM YOUR SIDE ON THE
HOUSE SIDE, THESE THREE WORKERS,
EMPLOYEES AND THIS WUHAN
CORONAVIRUS LAB STUDYING THESE
BAD CORONAVIRUS IS WERE SICK
WITH AN ILLNESS, OBVIOUSLY BLOOD
SAMPLES TAKEN, HAD TO BE.
HOW CAN WE AS A GOVERNMENT
PRESSURE THEM TO RELEASE THOSE
BLOOD TESTS AND ONCE WE GET THE
ANSWER THERE, WE SHOULD HAVE A
PRETTY DEFINITIVE ANSWER.
THERE WAS AN EARLY INFECTION
FROM THAT LAB, I THINK WE CAN
ISOLATE THE LAB THEORY AND SAY
THAT THE LIKELIHOOD AT THIS
POINT.
>> THAT'S THE REASON THE SENATE
AND I GIVE THEM CREDIT
UNANIMOUSLY VOTED TO DECLASSIFY
THIS INFORMATION BEGINNING TO
GET IT OUT THERE BECAUSE THE
ONLY WAY TO GET OUT OF THIS BEEN
ARE NOT A CONSPIRACY THEORIST TO
UNDERSTAND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS THE LEADER OF
THE FREE WORLD AND IS THE LEADER
OF THE FREE WORLD USING VAST
AMOUNTS OF MONEY AND INFLUENCE
TO STIFLE THE KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT RICK SAW WHEN
HE WAS THE DIRECTOR THAT IN FACT
THEY NEED TO HAVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND TO GET TO THE
TRUTH, NOT GOING TO GET TO THE
TRUTH AS LONG AS THEY HAVE
INFLUENCE OVER TECH AND MEDIA IN
A GREAT MANY POLITICIANS
INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT